قد تكون قطعه الايس كريم هذه افضل وجبه
تناولتها هذه الغوريلا منذ زمن في قفصها
في برلين خاصه مع درجات الحراره الملتهبه
التي اشعلت كوكب الارض حتى ولو لم يمضي
على دخول فصل الصيف بضعه اسابيع فخلال
الاسبوع الماضي سجلت الارض متوسطه درجات
حراره هي الاعلى في تاريخ الكوكب لثلاثه
ايام متتاليه تراوحت بين سبع عشره فاصل
صفر واحد درجه مئويه وسبع عشره فاصله 23
درجه مئويه خلال تلك الايام وفقا لبيانات
مؤشر تحليل المناخ التابع لجامعه
الامريكيه ليس هذا فحسب بل صنف شهر يونيو
الماضي بانه الاكثر حرا على الاطلاق وفقا
لما سجله مرصادو كوبرنيكوس لتغير المناخ
بالاتحاد الاوروبي عشرات الدول في العالم
تعيش حاليا موجات حر الاستثنائيه وقاتله
من بينها العراق والصين والمكسيك والمانيا
والهند اودت بحياه العشرات وتسببت بنفوق
المواشي وتلف المحاصيل الزراعيه علماء
وصفوا ما وصل اليه العالم بالمرعب
والمجهول الا انهم لم يعتبره صادما في ظل
تجاهل العالم للتحذيرات المستمره حول
ضروره ابطاء الاحتباس الحراري الناجم عن
انبعاثات الغازات الملوثه اضافه لظاهره
النينو المناخيه في المحيط الهادئ التي
تحدث نتيجه تباين في درجات حراره المياه
ما يؤدي الى اندفاع كميه كبيره منها الى
الغلاف الجوي فتؤثر على الطقس العالمي